selon les experts la condition pour que
l'on parle et que l'on se souvienne de
quelque chose c'est avant tout sa
renommée ainsi pendant la seconde guerre
mondiale on a beaucoup parlé des
chasseurs qui apparaissent dans ce film
et ils trouveront tous leur place dans
les annales de l'histoire de l'aviation
en tant qu'avion de légende
chaque avion avait ses propres qualités
ses propres défauts ce qui imposait des
adaptations comptes aux tactiques
employées par les pilotes
chaque avion a ainsi connu des succès et
des échecs et susciter soit une forte
affection soit une profonde antipathie
chez les pilotes qui les utilisaient
certains de ces chasseurs ont vraiment
changé le cours de l'histoire
d'autres ont marqué la fin d'une époque
dans l'histoire de leur conception
alors que d'autres au contraire ont
défriché de nouveaux concepts techniques
les chasseurs des nombreux pays
impliqués dans la guerre n'allait pas
tous alignés victoire sur victoire
pourtant ils trouveront tous leur propre
place dans le panthéon du monde de
l'aviation
il a souvent été dit avec raison que la
capacité d'évolution d'un avion tout au
long de sa carrière constitue là un
atout essentiel
ainsi un avion au cours de sa carrière
doit être apte à recevoir des
modifications structurelles à s'adapter
à de nouveaux moteurs toujours plus
grands et plus puissants à intégrer des
armements de plus en plus lourd et
accueillir de nouveaux équipements
opérationnels
tout cela doit être possible sans la
nécessité d' une reconception
approfondie de ces composants essentiels
qui obligerait alors à une
restructuration trop importante
toutes ces qualités se révéleront
essentiel le messerschmitt bf 109
chasseurs allemands monoplace est un
excellent exemple d'avion possédant dès
le départ toutes les qualités requises
quant à d'éventuelles évolutions les
derniers modèles de la production finale
différé radicalement du prototype
original de 1935
mais les changements ont été apportés au
fur et à mesure et ainsi l'apport de
nouvelles machines aux différentes et ce
cadre il ne s'est jamais arrêté
il a été dit que le bf 109 a servi de
prototype pour la construction d'un
chasseur internationale sans aller
jusque là il a toutefois fait référence
en matière de chasseurs monoplan
monoplace à ailes basses et surpuissant
en fait il n'a fait ses débuts que
quelques semaines avant la mise en
service du hawker hurricane britannique
est juste six mois avant son principal
adversaire d'un super marine spitfire
les il a atteint son prestige militaire
bien avant ses adversaires et alliés
contemporain est il allé ultérieurement
avoir le privilège d'être produit en un
nombre bien supérieur par rapport aux
autres avions de combats de la seconde
guerre mondiale
lors de ses débuts il paraissait manquer
de classe mais le succès vain avec la
maturité en dépit des nombreux défauts
quand était largement rendu public le bf
109 fut en fait un très grand avion de
combat aux nombreuses victoires
le bf 109 a été conçue durant l'été 1934
lorsque le ministre de l'aviation
allemande manifesta le besoin de
construire un monoplan de combat
intercepteurs et monoplace afin de
remplacer les biplans henkel h 51
yar'adua air 68 avions devenu obsolète
au sein de la luftwaffe
le messerschmitt bf 109 fut le chasseur
monoplace standards de la luftwaffe
pendant presque une décennie
aucun chiffre exact n'est disponible sur
le nombre total de bf 109 assemblée mais
on pense que plus de 33000 d'entre eux
ont été fabriquées entre 1936 et la fin
de la seconde guerre mondiale ce qui
représente à plus de 60% de tous les
chasseurs monomoteur construit par
l'allemagne
durant cette période ayant combattu sur
tous les fronts sur lesquels la
luftwaffe fut engagé ayant été fabriqués
en plus grand nombre que tout autre
appareil de combat de ce type le
messerschmitt bf 109 avec toutefois une
célébrité légèrement inférieur aux
spitfires supermarine peut être qualifié
comme l'un des véritables immortels de
la seconde guerre mondiale
aucun avion de combat n'a jamais atteint
la perfection mais lors de ses débuts le
f w190 s'en approcha bien près ce comme
aucun autre chasseur c'était un brillant
concept dans lequel la maîtrise du poids
et la simplicité de fabrication furent
les idées forces tout en ne modifiant
pas la solidité structurelle de ce
nouvel avion
mais ce chasseur magnifiquement
proportionnée ne fut pas seulement un
avion de plus il fut conçu avec une
attention toute particulière afin de
résoudre les problèmes de fabrication et
d'entretien sur la piste les pilotes de
ce chasseur et des chasseurs adverses
ont chanté ses louanges et ses
apparitions lors des combats aériens ont
offert à la luftwaffe une supériorité
certes temporaire mais flagrante sur ses
adversaires du moment
sa maniabilité hors pair en virage à
grande vitesse virage qui auraient brisé
les ailes de la plupart de ses
contemporains lui ont valu un respect
immédiat parmi les pilotes de la rfm ont
sérieusement à l'armée le ministère de
l'armée de l'air britannique
lorsqu en 1942 et un déserteur de la
luftwaffe se présenta par hasard aux
alliés avec son chasseur fw 190 à intact
l'étude approfondie de cet appareil
remarquable du faut que vous le fleuve
sobat a profondément influencé la pensée
militaire en grande bretagne cela a
directement conduit à la parution de la
spécification f 243 qui a conduit à la
conception du coeur de nombreuses
caractéristiques ont ainsi été
directement inspiré du fw 190 à quel
plus grand hommage aurait pu être rendu
à ce qui est indubitablement l'un des
plus belles avions de guerre que
l'allemagne ait jamais construit durant
l'automne 1937 le reich l'oph mystérieux
mme ordonna avec la fox wulff la
construction d'un nouveau chasseur
monoplace afin de seconde et le
messerschmitt bf 109 mètres un deuxième
verrou feu ainsi que semer et à le dire
les responsables du à hellemmes
le contrat fut conclue avec la fois que
roule
essentiellement parce que cette
compagnie n'était alors pas beaucoup
impliqué dans le développement d'autres
avions de combat et posséder une équipe
de conception hautement qualifiés avec à
sa tête le célèbre ingénieur courbe tang
les travaux sur le fw 190 évoluèrent
très vite et en moins de dix mois le
premier prototype allait être prêt pour
les essais en vol
mettant essentiellement un monoplan à
ailes basses avec un train
d'atterrissage très large
cet avion bénéficier par ailleurs d'un
merveilleux dessin et l'intégration de
l'imposant moteur en étoile frisé le
chef-d'oeuvre d'ingéniosité durant les
années de guerre et sans compter les
prototypes treize mille trois cent
soixante sept chasseurs 6634 chasseurs
bombardiers et chasseurs d'appui aérien
eve w190 furent construits ainsi que 67
et à 152 e s
le f w190 commença sa carrière en
ravissant à la rff la petite marge de
supériorité qu'elle avait durement
acquise lors des combats chasseurs
contre chasseurs de plus lors des
offensives terrestres
le f w190 approuvé par la suite qu'il
pouvait encaisser sans broncher de
sévères de mordre
il est certain que la supériorité
technique peut annuler une supériorité
numérique écrasante
ainsi les progrès techniques réunies
dans le messerschmitt à me 262 était
telle que cette incroyable avion vers la
fin de la guerre aurait pu redonner à
l'allemagne dans le ciel européen
la supériorité dont la luftwaffe avait
joué lors des premières années du
conflit
au contraire le m 262 devint le symbole
de l'indécision et de l'hésitation mme
état d'esprit avec lesquels les
dirigeants allemands empoisonnèrent les
programmes de fabrication d'avions du
pays le général r ndu d'être considéré
ce chasseur à moteur à réaction comme
superflu pour les besoins de la
luftwaffe et il pensait que l'allemagne
guesnerie la guerre avec les avions
conventionnels qu'elle avait déjà
produit
ce sentiment était partagé par le fils
de marshall match qui eut ouvertement
mettait même en doute le bien-fondé de
poursuivre ce travail expérimental
néanmoins et en dépit de l'attitude très
réticente que manifestèrent le ministère
de l'aviation et la luftwaffe anvers
chasseurs à réaction
une équipe qui s'occupait de la
conception du messin schmidt reste à
d'un enthousiasme sans faille pour ce
projet un nombre total de 568 m 262 ont
été construits jusqu'au 1er janvier 1945
et 865 autres furent fabriqués dans les
quatre premiers mois 2009 145 néanmoins
à peine plus de 100 ont participé à des
opérations
mais pour ceux qui ont été impliqués
dans des combats ils connurent un succès
remarquable
les dernières opérations avec les m 262
furent entreprises par une unité de
chasseurs d'élite la jg 44 et elles
furent menées par le général galant le 7
avril 1945 cette unité est équipée de
chasseurs et me 262 à un b les emportant
chacun des missiles air 4ème de 24 cm 5
de diamètre engagea le cours bas avec
une formation de bas une forteresse
volante au dessus de la west valley les
missiles furent lancés contre cette
formation alors hors de portée de canon
et en quelques minutes 25 forteresse
furent détruites
le restant de la formation larga ces
bombes puis s'enfuit à tous tel chez
elle le polikarpov 1,16 un chasseur
monoplace dans la conception remonte à
1932 allait acquérir sa réputation en
devenant le premier intercepteur elbaz
doté de trains d'atterrissage
complètement escamotable ce qui lui
permettait d'être opérationnels partout
dans le monde
pourtant paradoxalement l'union
soviétique bien qu étant la première
grande puissance de l'air à introduire
un chasseur d'un concept si avancé fut
la dernière à renoncer aux chasseurs
biplan le 1,16 méritait réellement plus
de reconnaissance que celle dont ils
allaient être gratifiés par la suite en
occident malgré les quelques caractère
rudimentaire de sa construction et de
son équipement
c'était là un chasseur solide et
extrêmement maniable sensiblement plus
rapide que tous les autres contemporains
elle une stabilité remarquable en vol et
surtout il offrait un blindage qui
protégeait ses pilotes à une époque où
un tel luxe tous n'étaient généralement
pas considérée comme nécessaire
ses concepteurs n'ont jamais réussi à
améliorer ses médiocres performances en
matière de décollage et d'atterrissage
qui le handicapé depuis sa création
pourtant une fois ces trains
d'atterrissage rentrée il était doté
d'une excellente maniabilité et il ne
fait aucun doute que cela a
remarquablement informé les forces de
l'air soviétique et l'industrie de
l'aviation
et cet enseignement ainsi été bénéfique
pour les chasseurs suivant le 1,16 fut
le précurseur d'un nouveau style dans la
conception d'un chasseur un dessin
maintes fois copié jusqu'à l'avènement
de l'avion à turboréacteur et de telle
sorte qu'il occupe une place unique dans
l'histoire des chasseurs
l'italie posséder deux chasseurs de
première génération durant la guerre et
le fiat g50 fut l'un d'entre eux cet
avion était certes plus long que la
plupart des chasseurs qu'il dit
affrontés lors de combats mais dans les
mains de pilotes expérimentés il a pu
cependant faire bonne impression
la plupart des pilotes de chasseurs
italiens rejetèrent l'utilisation de
code pink arrêtés ils préférèrent des
verrières sans toit avec des fenêtres
latérales
car ils pensaient qu'une utilisation de
ces premiers était déloyal et inhumaine
bien que plus petit que ses
contemporains et malgré son manque de
puissance
le fiat g50 été par la plupart des
pilotes reconnus pour être un rêve quant
à son pilotage et une joie pour le
manoeuvrer
la mise en service du chasseur machi
castaldi le deuxième des chasseurs
italiens première génération présente un
parallèle intéressant avec celui du
super meurinne spitfire en effet aucun
de ces chasseurs ne furent la
conséquence logique d'une série d'avions
de combat les concepteurs de ces deux
avions s'inspirait abondamment de leur
expérience d'avion à grande vitesse
expérience acquise avec les hydravions
de course le c200 était un monoplan à
ailes basses en porte-à-faux entièrement
métallique et il possédait un train
d'atterrissage hydrauliquement
rétractable il était par ailleurs
complètement caréné avec une verrière de
cockpit qui permettait un champ de
vision de 360 degrés bien qu'il ne
possédait pas toute l'élégance de
chasseurs tels que le spitfire ou le
messerschmitt bf 109 avec le moteur à
refroidissement liquide
le mc 200 a démontré qu'il possédait une
maniabilité exceptionnelle pour un
monoplan
sa stabilité est est de premier ordre et
le maniement d'une grande précision dans
n'importe quelles conditions
le taux de montée était très bon mais
l'une des remarquables caractéristiques
du chasseur machi castaldi était son
taux de plongée en service dans la
regione tikal emc2 s'en fut baptisé ça
et à ce qui peut être traduit comme à la
fois est clair et flèches les armes de
jupiter mais ce chasseur souffrait de
difficultés conceptuelles la plus grave
était sa tendance à partir en vrille
sans prévenir dans certaines
circonstances cela a été finalement
rectifié par des modifications qui ont
ainsi retardé les livraisons et
seulement 29 chasseurs sai états sont
entrés en service dès le 1er novembre
mais sur ces 29 12 était déjà hors
d'état de fonctionner les premiers
chasseurs ces états à entrer en action
formèrent une escadrille de 26 appareils
constituant le sixième groupe autonome
au de la première des huit jeunes et
caccia terrestre basés en sicile
ils ont participé à la guerre des airs
au dessus de malte où ils ont combattu
lankais week-end pour la première fois
il se révélèrent légèrement moins rapide
que les chasseurs britanniques ces
étapes possédait pourtant un taux de
montée largement supérieur et pouvait se
dégager de la ligne de mire de leurs
icahn avec facilité grâce à son
remarquable taux de plonger la structure
du mc 202 étaient pour l'essentiel
similaire à celle du ca y est à les
surfaces portantes arrière verticale et
horizontale et est identique tout comme
les ailes à la seule différence de
l'installation des réservoirs de
carburant
placé dans les sections interne de
voilure et qui venait s'ajouter à ceux
du fuselage
la verrière derrière l'appuie tête du
pilote dont était équipé le prototype
fut supprimée sur le modèle de
production attendu que le carénage
arrière extrêmement fins rendait
l'installation initiale inutile ainsi la
structure anti couple située derrière la
tête du pilote fut remplacée par une
monture renforcée de la verrière
lorsqu'il entre en service le mc 202 fut
surnommé folger littéralement l'éclair
et les premiers chasseurs de ce type à
tenir la libye le 25 novembre 1941 ils
constituèrent la première story
remplacèrent les six états qu'ils eurent
plus que des rôles d' escort et deux
chasseurs bombardiers
si lutte était possible de construire
les chasseurs machi castaldi en très
grand nombre la guerre aérienne en
afrique du nord et en méditerranée
aurait très bien pu prendre une autre
tournure
le commentaire d'un pilote de l'us air
force lors d'un essai en vol d'un paul
garret récupérés intacts se montra très
descriptif à propos des qualités du
chasseur machi castaldi ouah c'est une
crème d'avion
chaque heure qui sont que la royal air
force à plat maroc fut un chasseur
monoplan cantilever monoplace et à ailes
basses
le p 36 appellation officielle diop prix
du service avec la 20e escadrille de
chasse du corps de l'armée de l'air
américaine en avril 1938 le hawk
remplaça les vieux chasseur boeing p 26
pourtant dès leur entrée en service les
nouveaux chasseurs car tisseron
contraire une longue série de problèmes
conceptuels de ces vers des formations
de revêtements aux alentours des trains
d'atterrissage apparurent et les
ingénieurs furent obligés de remplacer
les revêtements par d'autres largement
plus épais et doté de nervures renforcée
le système d'échappement apporte à lui
aussi son lot de difficultés et andé
cela par ailleurs des faiblesses dans la
structure du fuselage
pourtant malgré tous ces problèmes les
forces américaines et britanniques
trouvèrent que ce chasseur possédez
d'excellentes caractéristiques pour le
service en escale surtout grâce à sa
grande capacité à plonger rapidement
cependant dès le début de la guerre bien
que les britanniques et les américains
utilisaient des variantes due aux coûts
du moc ces chasseurs furent rapidement
considéré comme des machines obsolètes
et dès 1941 il fut remplacé
progressivement par des chasseurs plus
efficace
la carte id p 40 fut sans aucun doute
l'un des chasseurs les plus
controversées à servir en grande
quantité durant la seconde guerre
mondiale il fut ainsi glorifier et
diffamer mais le fait est qu'en tant que
premier chasseur monoplace américain il
essuya le plus fort de la guerre au
dessus de plusieurs champs de bataille
ses performances étaient inférieures à
celles de la majorité de ses
antagonistes mais ce défaut fut en
partie compensé par sa versatilité sa
solidité qui lui permirent de faire face
à un nombre considérable d'affront ils
pouvaient être facilement transformé et
il fut toujours disponibles lorsqu'on en
use cruellement besoin
on comprendre les motivations qui
donnèrent naissance au p 40 il est
nécessaire de se rendre compte de la
pensée stratégique américaine au début
des années 30 entre les deux guerres
mondiales la mise en exploitation du
chasseur aux usa fut relativement faible
comparée à celle des autres pays en
effet les préoccupations du corps de
l'armée de l'air américaine porte
essentiellement sur les bombardiers à
grand rayon d'action
il était la priorité et les chasseurs ne
recevait alors que des crédits
budgétaires limitées à cette période il
y avait une très faible marge de
rendement entre les bombardiers les
chasseurs les américains pensaient que
la force de frappe défensive de
bombardier serait largement suffisante
face à la capacité de destruction des
chasseurs
lorsque le cahier des charges du p 40
fut oublié aucune perspective d'
attaques ennemies à haute altitude
contre les usa n'était alors envisagé et
c'est pourquoi la défense côtière et la
capacité offensive terrestre furent les
principales exigences les qualités de
vol à basse altitude ainsi que la
solidité de l'assemblage ont par
conséquent été considérés comme
prioritaires
de fait le paie 40 allait par la suite
se révéler une excellente arme
d'offensive terrestre
mais à l'époque de l'attaqué japonaise
sur pearl harbour ce chasseur était déjà
presque obsolète alors qu'ils étaient
assemblés que depuis seulement deux ans
mais en moins jusqu'en 1944 date de
l'arrêt de la production du pays 40 un
nombre total de treize mille sept cent
trente huit chasseurs avaient été livrés
à l us a à f avec un point culminant de
2499 appareils en service atteint en
avril 1944
le bien aimé d'okinawa pour le corps de
la marine américaine
la mort sifflante pour les japonais et
l'oiseau zèle tordu pour les forces
terrestres américaines qui se protège
air sous l'imposant parapluie
d'artillerie qu'il déployait dans le
pacifique
le corsaire fut universellement reconnu
pour être le meilleur chasseur de la
marine américaine durant la seconde
guerre mondiale beaucoup de personnes et
plus particulièrement les pilotes ont
été plus loin en le désignant comme le
meilleur chasseur monoplace parmi tous
les appareils américains conçu lors de
ce conflit malgré ses formidables
qualités et le fait qu'il fut
explicitement destinés à servir comme
appareil embarqué sur porte-avions le
corsair a passé la plupart de sa
carrière militaire confinés sur des
bases terrestres et ce ne fut pas avant
la fin de l'année 1944 qu'il réalise à
ses premières sorties opérationnelles
sur pantalon américain dans le pacifique
mais les mêmes problèmes qu'il avait
retenu après son introduction sur les
ponts des porte-avions de l'us navy
pendant près de deux ans jusqu'à sa mise
en service opérationnelle lui ont
soudain donné l'occasion de prouver sa
supériorité
il opérera à partir des pistes basée à
guadalcanal et sur les îles salomon les
us marines transformer le cancer en une
arme de suprématie aérienne ils
combattirent les chasseurs 0 sur un pied
d'égalité pour la première fois dans le
conflit du pacifique et la chance tourne
at dès lors presque systématiquement en
faveur des forces alliées lors des
combats aériens
le jour de la victoire des alliés sur le
japon 1912 f 4 u avait été assemblé
mais par la suite les contrats furent
réduits de 3149 à 2356 appareils pour
cette version du corsaire pourtant
quelques sept ans et demi s'écoulèrent
avant que le dernier modèle de cette
incroyable chasseurs james root
disparaissent des nouvelles chaînes de
production de dallas
après la guerre le corsaire aller jouir
d'une brillante carrière dans la période
la plus remarquable fut la campagne de
corée ce magnifique chasseurs allait
encore servir jusque dans les années 60
durant sa longue lui le corset reconnu
980 une modification importante et
quelques vingt mille transformation
mineurs mais la cellule reste à
pratiquement inchangé ainsi ces
modifications lui confie nerfs des
qualités qui allait lui valoir la
distinction d'être le dernier chasseur à
élise construit aux usa il aura ainsi
survécu à tous ses contemporains aussi
bien sur porte-avions qu'à partir de
bases terrestres
lorsqu'en janvier 1943 la 56e escadrille
de chasseurs de l'us airforce arrive au
royaume uni avec ses énormes république
p47 de boxe les pilotes de chasse de la
rfa ci lui air avec un ton moqueur que
leurs collègues américains seraient
capables d'échapper au feu ennemi
lorsqu'ils seraient attaqués en
détachant leur harnais et en allant se
planquer dans le fuselage de l'art
énorme monture le fun de bolt était sans
aucun doute imposant en fait ce fut le
plus grand et le plus lourd chasseur
monoplace monomoteur jamais construit
mais sa grande taille n'allait pas nuire
à sa carrière opérationnelle bien au
contraire
il allait entreprendre pas moins de 540
6000 sortie en combat entre mars 1943 et
août 1945 et seulement 0 7% des
chasseurs de ce type envoyé contre
l'ennemi allait être perdu lors de ses
combats
l'histoire du thunderbolt commence en
juin 1940 quand se rendant compte des
imperfections de l'équipement des
chasseurs de loups et acer france de
nouvelles exigences furent formulées
lors d'une réunion à wright field
parmi les compagnies qui furent
consultés quant à la conception de ce
nouveau chasseur se trouvait la nouvelle
république avec sean corpore sano
cette dernière possédait en effet une
expérience inestimable dans la
conception de chasseurs expérience
hérité de ses prédécesseurs à césar ce
qui est à kraft comparer chaîne
l'ingénieur chef de république alexander
karrer nick hamm est à cette époque en
chantier un nouveau chasseur sur ses
planches à dessin chasseurs qui l'avait
nommé x p 47
ce chasseur qui se conformer à la
politique officielle de l'époque au
moment de sa conception était un
appareil relativement léger il fut conçu
autour d'un moteur allison avait 12 2000
150 chevaux à refroidissement liquide et
était armé de deux canons de 50
mais l'estimation des performances de ce
futur appareil était bien loin de celles
étant considéré comme essentiel pour le
futur chasseur de l'ueh sky karrde
valley ainsi abandonna ce chasseur dotée
du moteur allison est mis aussi de côté
le prototype admis aboutie du p 44 afin
de se concentrer totalement sur le
développement d'un chasseur radicalement
différent les premières tâches du tim
holt qui commença sa carrière le 8 avril
1943 fut d'escorté des avions à haute
altitude et d'accomplir une surveillance
aérienne du territoire et ce malgré
l'inexpérience de ce qu'ils veulent ils
se sont en fait vite aperçu que
l'imposant thibauld pouvait à haute
altitude se dégager de n'importe quel
appareil de la luftwaffe et même
d'ailleurs de ceux des alliés il
disposait d'une puissance décisive afin
de rompre le combat lorsque cela était
nécessaire mais à basse ou moyenne
altitude il ne pouvait pas rivaliser
avec les chasseurs allemands que ce soit
en termes de taux de montée ou en
matière de manoeuvrabilité l'un des
défauts encore plus flagrant que chez
d'autres chasseurs alliés fut son rayon
d'action par trop limitée qui ne lui
permettait aucune incursion très
profonde au coeur de l'allemagne mais
les ingénieurs cherchait déjà un moyen
d'ajouter op 47 b 1190 litres de
carburant on encore interne à l'époque
où le thymol entra en scène en europe
les chasseur monoplace à moteur en
étoile était une rareté
le seul autre chasseur de ce type
opérationnelle en europe était le fw 190
ha
ainsi afin d'éviter toute confusion
entre les deux chasseurs provenant de
camps opposés les capotages du moteur du
thibauld furent peints en blanc et des
bandes de la même couleur a posé sur les
surfaces de l'empennage vertical et
horizontal
c'était bien entendu là un moyen
efficace de reconnaître depuis le sol
l'appartenance de ces appareils à cette
époque mais il semble tout de même bien
difficile voire impossible de confondre
le chasseur allemand aux lignes si pures
et aux magnifiques profil pour un
corpulent thibolt durant l'année 1944
thibauld fut opérationnel sur tous les
théâtres des hostilités excepté en
alaska et il servi aussi bien avec les
forces libres françaises et russes
qu'avec lui la fnars
le p 47 des fûts surtout employé sur des
missions d'attaqué terrestre à long
rayon d'action est il du mont-bart des
mitrailler les liaisons de
communications les terrains d'aviation
les ponts et les concentrations de
troupes durban tshwane stoffel où diable
à double que à sobriquet qui ne fut pas
employé à la légère par la luftwaffe
afin de qualifier le look il p 38
lightning
ce dernier cause en effet des dommages
considérables sur les lignes japonaises
et allemandes
bien que le lightning fut produit en un
nombre plus limité que tout autre
principal chasseur de combat de l'uefa f
avec un chiffre total de production de
9923 appareils
jusqu en août 1945 ce chasseur a servi
sur tous les fronts et dans de très
divers rôles où il dut bombardé évacuer
les blessés et enfumé ses adversaires
s'il était légèrement plus lent et moins
manoeuvrable qu'ernst un goût qu'un
thibauld le lightning offrait l'avantagé
d'être équipé de deux moteurs un facteur
de capacité de survie incomparable et de
posséder un rayon d'action exceptionnel
mais le lightning fut surtout
intéressant pour le nombre et la variété
de ses innovations en plus d'être le
premier projet de lockheed dans le
domaine militaire
le lightning fut le premier chasseur
d'escadrille conçu selon le principe de
la configuration allongeront unique être
adopté par les usa m il fut aussi le
premier chasseur monoplace bi moteur
utilisé par cette armée de l'air au
printemps 1944 ont dénombré très
escadrille de p 38 dans les services
d'intervention à l'étranger ou
combattez-les usa et en europe
le lightning est la neuvième air force
tactique servir principalement ensemble
cet avion
opéra en tant qu escorte de chasseurs à
long rayon d'action mais il accomplit
aussi des attaques terrestres
par contre dans le pacifique leur rayon
d'action exceptionnel les placer en
première ligne lors de la conquête
progressive des îles les premières
missions des scores de bombardier sur
berlin fürth entreprises par des
lightning
même s'ils furent surclassé en combat
aérien par les f w190 et plus tard par
les bf 109 incomparablement plus
manoeuvrable mais dans le pacifique les
lightning à bâtir plus d'avions japonais
que n'importe quel autre avion
d'ailleurs le meilleur pilote de chasse
américains de la seconde guerre mondiale
l'ancien commandant riche bang
remportant en tout 40 victoires alors
qu'il pilotait un p38 lors de ces
opérations
mcguire un autre pilote de lightning le
suivi de près avec 38 victoires sur les
japonais alors qu'en europe
jenkins ait remporté respectivement
et 22 victoires avec twilight grâce à sa
grande capacité de chargement le
lightning fait aussi utilisé à des fins
pour le moins inhabituel vers la fin de
la guerre lorsque les cargos et les
conteneurs furent adaptés pour la tâche
de mâts supports de bombes les
escadrilles indépendante de p 38 dans le
pacifique emportèrent des cargaisons de
pièces de rechange pour les équipes au
sol afin de pouvoir utiliser les pistes
d'atterrissage dont il venait de
s'emparer ce sans avoir à attendre
l'arrivée des transports d'appui dans
d'autres occasions pour des évacuations
aérienne rapide de blessés le lightning
devint alors une ambulance de l'ère des
réservoirs largable modifié doté de
n'est transparent furent construits à
l'occasion afin de transporter chacun
d'eux blessé une autre application
inhabituel fut d'utiliser certains p38
comme remorqueurs de planeur à 6 chaque
appareil pouvait remarquer un maximum de
trois planeurs chargé on a même équipe
et un lightning de ski afin de le faire
décoller sur piste enneigée
il fut ainsi normal que le lightning
achève sa brillante carrière militaire
en étant le premier appareil de l'uefa f
à atterrir au japon lors de la victoire
finale
l'appareil que vous allez maintenant
découvrir fut indiscutablement le
meilleur chasseur américain de la
seconde guerre mondiale et peut-être
même le meilleur de tous les chasseurs
alliés mais le north american hosting
p-51 fut presque conçu par accident
concernant la vitesse le rayon d'action
et la manoeuvrabilité il était plus
performant que tous les autres appareils
de lui et ça m est bien que produit en
quantité légèrement inférieur comparé
aux thibauld p 47
il a finalement remplacé ce dernier dans
tout les escadrilles sauf la 8e
le mustang s'est aussi illustré comme le
principal chasseur stratégique allié sa
réputation avec l'usf s'était fait lors
des deux dernières années de la guerre
la première escadrille de combat arrive
au royaume uni en novembre 1943
le général à paroles a d'ailleurs
reconnu que l' us af avait fait l'erreur
de ne pas avoir utilisé beaucoup plus
tôt cet excellent chasseur en fait
c'était seulement par hasard que la
mustang plus acceptés par lui et sert
you must ang doit son existence à la
commission de l'armée de l'air
britannique qui fut à l'origine du
cahier des charges
en effet cette commission demande à un
remplaçant pour le kart xp 40 car elle
considérait ce dernier comme étant
inadapté sur le théâtre des opérations
en europe la north american aviation pu
consulter par la commission sur la
possibilité de fabriquer un chasseur qui
satisferait au cahier des charges publié
mais cette commission stipule a vu la
gravité de la guerre qu'un prototype
devrait être achevé en moins de 120
jours
grâce à un effort presque surhumain le
premier chasseur prototype baptisé par
ces constructeurs sous la désignation de
haine à 73 sortie de l' usine
d'assemblage en 117 jours pourtant les
essais qui allait amener le mustang à
devenir le chasseur multifonctions par
excellence furent entrepris non pas par
neuf américaine mais par rolls royce
le commandant thomas dietsch coque alors
militaires américains attachés à londres
rapporte à washington à l'automne 1942
que le p 51 avait l'une des meilleures
sinon la meilleure cellule de chasseurs
à cette date et il conseilla de
transformer ce nouvel appareil en un
chasseur haute altitude en le
m'autorisant avec un rolls royce merlin
cette opinion fut appuyée par des
autorités et el kébir week-end bakker et
le maréchal de l'air certes trafford
l'agm à l'orgue ainsi 4,9 temples furent
livrés à rolls royce pour la
transformation
l'escort à haute altitude et de combat
devant les points forts d'une sangle et
au dessus de 20 mille pieds il fut
supérieur en vitesse et manoeuvrabilité
à tous les chasseurs allemand doté d'un
moteur à pistons même au pire moment de
la guerre alors que cet avion devait par
faire une mise au point rendue difficile
par une conception toute nouvelle les
rapids opérations de mutations et de
transformation que subit le mustang
furent phénoménal
le mustang bâti des records depuis sa
conception pour le moins inspiré il
finit comme probablement le meilleur
chasseur monoplace multifonction est mue
par un moteur à pistons de tout
l'inventaire de la seconde guerre
mondiale
la synthèse de plusieurs années
d'expérience approfondi dans la
conception de chasseurs biplan a conduit
à exprimer cette nouvelle formule pour
le chasseur du futur un compromis entre
la tradition et les besoins nés d'une
nouvelle époque dans la guerre aérienne
tel fut hawker hurricane en étant le
premier chasseur monoplan à rejoindre la
royal air force et le premier avion de
combat capables de dépasser les 400 80
km/heure en vol en palier leur week-end
se taillaient la part du lion dans la
défense aérienne britannique durant la
bataille d'angleterre
il fut largement responsables du succès
de ce conflit en équipant près de 70%
des escadrille de chasseurs de là et
rêve
le week end et montera aussi qu'il
possédait une stupéfiante capacité
d'adaptation
les multiples tâches auxquelles ils su
s'adapter lui valent la distinction
d'avoir été sans aucun doute le plus
versatile des chasseurs monoplace de la
seconde guerre mondiale certains
constructeurs d'avions excelle dans la
diversité de leurs produits
d'autres construisent leur succès sur la
poursuite inébranlable d'une solide et
les deux méthodes en leur avantage et
elles ont mené à la production
d'excellents avions mais là au coeur
conçu par la société à kraft fut le seul
exemple remarquable d'un constructeur
dévoué à un seul projet
cette compagnie qui élabora son nouvel
appareil à partir du rapport ça pour
yves a passé sa vie à développer des
avions monomoteurs en conséquence le nom
de hacker s'est ajouté à ceux de
nombreux autres avions illustres mais
aucun n'a réussi à se rendre plus
célèbre que le week-end le début de
carrière du week-end fut dans plusieurs
domaines très similaire à celui du
supermarine spitfire avec lequel il
allait former une équipe immortel mais
alors que le spitfire fut le fruit d'une
conception totalement nouvelle
le riken fut la conséquence logique
d'une longue série d'avions de combat
ainsi bien que ces deux avions est
satisfait en général le même exigence
faisant présentait des approches
totalement différente quant à des
cahiers des charges pourtant identique
leur apparence respectives refléter
d'ailleurs ces deux approches le travail
sur le week-end fut énergique et acharné
celui effectué sur le spitfire fut
délicat et minutieux l'influent
l'application rigoureuse de l'expérience
l'autre un coup de génie
après le déclenchement de la guerre le
week-end entre a rapidement en action
avec les escadrilles 1 et 73 qui furent
les premières à être basés en france
comme force de frappe de l'air en poste
avancé cet avion confirma le bien fondé
de sa conception en obtenant sa première
victoire sur le front occidental le 30
octobre 1939
jusqu'à la fin de l'année 1940
américaine représente à l'effectif le
plus important de chasseurs britanniques
en service lorsque la bataille
d'angleterre comment ça il y avait en
ordre de marche dans la f30 escadrille
de ricaner 19 escadrille de spitfire et
ce fut bien entendu le week-end qui
essuya le plus fort de la tacc
germanique
entre juillet et novembre 1940 la
versatilité du week-end n'a jamais été
surpassé par aucun autre avion de combat
quelle que soit la mission qu'il est
entrepris il a accompli sa tâche avec
distinction
le week-end a largement mérité sa place
parmi les avions de combat exceptionnel
de l'histoire de l'aviation
il fut l'un des paradoxes de l'histoire
de l'aviation en étant l'un de ses
excellents appareil à obtenir ses titres
de gloire en accomplissant des missions
pour lesquelles il n'était pas destiné
il eu dans ce domaine de meilleur
exemple que celui du mosquito en effet
s'il fut conçu pour devenir un
bombardier
il est devenu au contraire l'un des
chasseurs les plus puissants de la
guerre en plus de cela il fut
probablement le chasseur le plus
polyvalent de tous les appareils bi
moteurs construits entre 1939 et 1945
et contrairement au vieil adage selon
lequel on ne peut être bon tout il
excella dans toutes les tâches qui lui
furent confiées il eu pour mission
d'être bombardier pour des attaques à
haute et basse altitude de jour comme de
nuit mais il sut aussi se transformer en
avion de reconnaissance militaire à long
rayon d'action pour la prise de photos
en mouillage de mines ou encore en avion
éclaireur il devint avec le même
savoir-faire transporteur militaire à
grande vitesse chasseurs de jour et de
nuit à long rayon d'action ou encore
chanson bombardier il a servi en europe
au moyen extrême orient ou sur le front
russe
en fait la mini présent mosquito régnant
en maître absolu parmi les appareils de
la general purpose skype et sur le
nombre total de 7500 81 mosquito
construit 6710 furent livrés durant la
guerre
l'histoire du mosquito comment ça durant
l'été 1938 l'année de l'actrice de
munich lorsque la commission des
highland commença à songer à la
construction d'un bombardier à grande
vitesse
l'essentiel de la conception du
bombardier des amis l'indre ont posé sur
la vitesse et non sur l'armement pour sa
défense
et c'est cet accent sur la performance
qui a donné aux mosquito son immense
succès en tant que chasseur
lors de sa conception en tant que
bombardier il fut construit pour être
plus performant que tous les chasseurs
existants pour cette raison en tant que
chasseur il allait devenir exceptionnel
comme la production augmenter dé
escadrille de bombardiers et de
chasseurs furent constitués durant
l'hiver 1941 42 20 mosquito furent
livrés à la fin de l'année 1941 et la
première cinquantaine en mars 1942 mais
chasseurs mosquito de base qui rejoint
son escadrille en 1942 fut le nf mark ii
il était à l'origine équipé comme un
chasseur de nuit et il fut utilisé en
tant que défenseur du territoire
britannique avec le bristol brighter son
armement était composé de quatre canons
de 20 mm situé sur l'avant et quatre
mitrailleuses branding de 77 mm à
l'extrémité du nez
dans la nuit du 28 au 29 mai 1942 les
mosquito nf2 ont détruit leurs premiers
appareils ennemis et durant les trois
années qui suivirent les chasseurs venus
mosquito ont approximativement a battu
600 avions allemands au dessus des îles
britanniques et ils ont aussi réussi à
éliminer quelques 600 bombes volantes en
deux mois
plus tard ils ont opéré en tant qu'avion
d'appui aérien
leur tâche était de défendre le
principal groupe de gros bombardier au
dessus du territoire ennemi
pas moins de 27 différentes versions du
mosquito ont été mises en service durant
la guerre et certaines des opérations
parmi les plus spectaculaires de la
guerre aérienne pourrait être accompli
grâce à lui
le mosquito emporta des charges
phénoménal sur des distances extrêmement
longue
en exécutant des prouesses
exceptionnelles comparé aux
caractéristiques qui furent envisagées
lors de sa conception
en bref le mosquito fut un avion hors du
commun
la supermarine spitfire est bien plus
qu'un excellent chasseur c'est le
symbole matériel de la victoire finale
pour les britanniques pendant la période
la plus sombre de leur histoire et c'est
probablement le seul chasseur de la
seconde guerre mondiale à avoir atteint
un véritable statut légendaire aucun
autre chasseur ne mérite plus sa place
au panthéon de l'aviation et où jusqu'à
40 modèles différents assemblée il fut
construit en très grande quantité par
rapport aux autres avions britanniques
il a volé en opération sur presque tous
les fronts entre 1939 et 1945 et il a
servi dans toutes les grandes batailles
aériennes menées par la rfa cette époque
à partir de 1938 spitfire fut le sujet
d'un programme de développement intense
lequel allait rester la principale
préoccupation de l'équipe de conception
du spitfire durant plusieurs années les
ingénieurs de la firme supermarine et
carter ainsi la présentation de tout
autre avion de combat durant la guerre
plusieurs axes de recherche ont ainsi vu
le jour en même temps le premier
concerne à l'amélioration de
l'aérodynamisme donc des performances
cela consistait à exploiter les
augmentations successives de puissance
du moteur rolls royce merlin la deuxième
concerne à l'augmentation de l'armement
le troisième la capacité d'emport
interne en carburant et finalement le
dernier dû adapter la pareille à des
rôles aussi différent que celui de la
reconnaissance photographique ou de
chasseurs embarqués sur porte-avions le
premier principal développement se
rapporte à à la motorisation dans la
marche normale du développement des
recherches ont été effectuées afin
d'améliorer les performances en altitude
du spitfire ces dernières étant bien
inférieure à celle du bf 109 e
il y eut ainsi deux modifications
majeures la mise en place d'une cabine
pressurisée et l'utilisation d'un moteur
adapté aux très hautes altitudes
pour un avion qui fut à l'origine
destiné à être un pur intercepteurs à
court rayon d'action le spitfire se
montra remarquablement souple quant à
son adaptation du début jusqu'à la fin
de la guerre il fut à la pointe du
combat les spitfire ont combattu au
dessus des plages de dunkerque est
au-dessus des plages du débarquement
quelques quatre ans plus tard ils ont
appuyé la 14e armée en birmanie ils ont
participé à l'invasion de la grèce et
plus tôt en 1943 ils ont repoussé
l'attaqué japonaise sur darwin en
australie
ils ont volé sur les îles salomon bornéo
et la nouvelle guinée
en fait le spitfire à opérer partout où
la rfm impliqués mais presque tous les
pilotes de chasse sont un jour ou
l'autre volet sur cet appareil
les alliés ou les ennemis ont souvent
rendu hommage à cet avion mais le plus
remarquable de ces hommages fut formulée
par le général allemand adolf galam qui
allait devenir plus tard le général des
escadrille de chasseurs de la luftwaffe
alors qu'il rendait visite aux
basé sur les côtes de la manche
le rush marshall gehring se plaignent
amèrement des pertes qui avaient subi
les formations de bombardier de la
luftwaffe lors des attaques sur
l'angleterre
gary affirmé que les chasseurs devaient
apporter une protection plus efficace
barbier il demanda alors en général
galant quelles étaient ses besoins en
matière de chasseurs ce à quoi galles en
réplique à une escadrille de spitfire
plus de 22000 spitfire et 2,6 fire /
construit la conception du spitfire
incarner l'ingéniosité technique et
aucun avion de combat n'a aussi bien
servi son pays que cet appareil
le supermarine spitfire sera
incontestablement le seul avion de la
seconde guerre mondiale dont le souvenir
restera immortel
à la fin de la guerre en 1945 la
conception des chasseurs à moteur à
pistons avait atteint son apogée et de
ce fait de nouvelles idées de conception
aller voir le jour sur les planches à
dessin en utilisant les nouveaux types
de groupes propulseurs
ainsi cela devenait soudainement une
impression de quasi léthargique quant
aux performances des chasseurs de la
seconde guerre
les puissances aériennes du monde
moderne était entré dans l'âge du
réacteur en effet l'avenir dans la
conception de chasseurs reposer
dorénavant sur ce type de propulsion
cette nouvelle race de chasseurs et
leurs pilotes allaient combattre dans
une toute nouvelle forme de guerre
aérienne
mais même les chasseurs les plus avancés
ne demeure qu'un savant mélange de
métallurgie et d'informatique jusqu'à ce
que le pilote presse le bouton où
poussent la première commande
ce fut presque la même chose de 1939 à
1945 lorsque la conception des chasseurs
avancer à pas de géant
principalement en termes de vitesse de
performance de puissance de feu et de
survie bilité l'avion aurait été inutile
sans les compétences des pilotes de
chasse à leurs commandes
il faut ainsi reconnaître que bien que
de nombreux chasseurs est atteint un
prestige légendaire dans les annales de
l'histoire de l'aviation militaire
cette histoire n'est pas seulement un
récit sur des appareils volant c'est
surtout une chronique des hommes et de
leurs machines